hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the power of nesting I am
soon Pam of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar hosted by lab roots and
presented by the Anderson lab bedding
products the Anderson lab batting
products is a manufacturer of a complete
range of premium bedding nesting and
enrichment products all aimed at making
an unnatural environment more natural
while they refer to know for the bed Oh
cops branded products of their product
lines now include a broad selection of
products designed to meet the needs of
today's lab their latest innovation of
the bed our nest represents a portion
controlled easy to dispense in Richmond
and nesting solution that offers
advantages for both the lab and the
animals from irradiated and qualified
products available in autoclavable and
bulk bags to sterility and heavy metal
testing they also provide a number of
services to the industry for more
information please visit www bedding com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can the large reply window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right of the right hand corner of the
slide window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems through the green Q&A button
lower left I would like now to turn over
to our speaker and your game Andrea
graduated from marie college in
jacksonville illinois with a bachelor's
degree in elementary education and
learning disabilities andrea has been
involved in lab animal industry for 15
years and she joined the Anderson lab
lending products in 2008 as a regional
sales manager Andrea
to give on the talk on the power of
nesting thank you all for attending my
talk I plan on covering the following
information on nesting what to nest look
like in the wild how do us in today's
lab compared to nest built in the wild
why should nesting material be used
what's in the nest and what this
research show about nesting so mice live
all over the world in nearly every
country and climate with that said mouse
nest can be created out of just about
anything there are many different types
of mice and each of them has their own
nesting behavior and habits which help
them survive for example a deer mouse
lives all over North America and lives
primarily in prairies and fields the
white-footed Mouse lives in forests and
brush lands and the canyon mouse makes
his home in the desert many of us are
familiar with the common house Mouse
which makes his home inside our homes
here's a picture of a mouse nest found
in nature notice the different materials
used to build this nest this mouse has
used feathers straw grasses and leaves
notice the shape of the nest and this
nest is about the size of a baseball
judging by the materials used to make
this nest it is safe to say this mouth
lives outside wild mice typically make a
burrow underground if they live outside
this helps protect them from their
natural predators most nests are made
from whatever the female Mouse can find
these next examples are made in
interesting environments the picture on
the left shows what looks like
insulation to build the nest on the
stove the picture on the right has
Kleenex and paper used to build the nest
in the glove compartment of the car
it goes to show that nest making is
instinctual mysle make a nest anywhere
it's what they do to survive so why do
mice build nests in the wild mice have a
strong internal instinct to build nests
building nests allows them to hide from
predators nests allow them to compensate
for external temperatures and helps them
create the less thermally stressful
habitat nets provides shelter from rain
wind snow and sun as much as a nest can
warm a mouse it can also cool them in a
heated environment mice using us to
sleep in it is their house shelter where
they sleep and raise their pups keeping
their pups out of view of predators is
very important sinisa materials are
driven by species environment and shapes
as we touched upon earlier the
environment where the mouse lives
determines what materials are available
for nest building wild mice will build a
nest anywhere inside rock walls san
fields and under logs even in your car
mice often adjust abandoned burrows by
adding extra entrances and tunnels
depending on the needs of the particular
species nests are characteristically
small and round and can vary in size
from three to six inches in diameter
mice like to shred any available
material and then build the nest in
layers here's a picture of a laboratory
room the typical lab environment for a
mouse is quite barren the cage
environment for multiple house mice
consists of bedding food and water some
facilities have in Richmond added
but that is not required unless the
animals are singly housed or breeders
typical cage environments are static
caging for ibc racks where air changes
are blown into the cage environment most
of the air coming into the cage is done
at the bedding level with a certain
number of air changes per hour a couple
of species typically used in the lab are
the c57 black sixes and the ball see 57s
tend to be sensitive to noise likely to
bite and fight typically they are an
aggressive species bulbs have a high
level of anxiety and are also aggressive
mice in the lab environment are living
in an unnatural environment that they
have no control over the temperature in
the cage is colder than they prefer in
many instances they have materials given
to them for enrichment that do not lend
themselves to nest building because of
this they tend to exhibit abnormal
behaviors most nesting material giving
in the lab today is for singularly
housed animals and breeders nesting
material is not given to every mouse
cage in the facility many studies and
posters have been published showing that
nesting material may help decrease
abnormal behaviors happy- don't exhibit
abnormal behaviors offering nesting
material enhances the well-being of lab
animals as they are able to perform more
of their species specific behaviors
breeding increases when nesting material
is used this may be attributed to the
lack of abnormal behaviors such as
cannibalization of pups but it can also
be attributed to using their energy on
breathing performance some nesting
material
given in the lab could also be given as
a fluke it's added to fulfill the
enrichment requirement so let's talk
about the beginning of nesting material
in 2004 a study was done regarding
nesting the mice were given a deep layer
of bedding for burrowing and body
temperature regulation the problem with
this was it only used one nesting
behavior the other problem was that
using too much bedding does not allow
the bedding to perform correctly which
then can compromise the cage environment
these two pictures show typical cages
with nesting material used today note
they are of singular housed animals the
cage on the left has a cotton square and
the cage on the right has a handful of
crinkle paper remember in nature they
drag all sorts of substances into their
nests to build own shaped round nests in
the lab generally one material is given
so why should nasty material be used
well lab rooms are too cold mice like
their environment temperature to be
between 26 and 34 Celsius this has been
documented most lab rooms are kept at 22
24 Celsius where we are comfortable IVC
racks are becoming more popular with
this we are pumping air changes in at
the bedding level and the animals have
nowhere to hide from the cold draft the
cold temperatures and the inability to
stay warm add stress increases food
consumption and increases abnormal
behaviors providing nesting materials
allow the mice to control their
environment they not only prefer their
instinctive behaviors
but these materials give them control
over the temperature in their
environment we know might as well all
through the quality of their nuts in
response to ambient temperature adding
nesting materials helps animal welfare
by reducing the variables in the study
added by stress being a warm-blooded
animal rodents generate their own heat
because of their large body surface to
body mass ratio they lose heat to the
environment easily they build nests to
keep their heat nesting material gives
the inferior mouse the opportunity to
keep out of sight and if needed to
escape from the dominant mouse the
dominant mouse then has no reason to be
aggressive providing nesting materials
allows the mice to control their
environment they not only perform their
instinctive behaviors but these
materials also give them control over
the temperature in their cage
environment providing a nest allows
their energy focus to be on breeding and
not only on thermal regulation one study
determined that when given nesting
materials not only do the breeding
groups produce more pups on average they
also consumed less food per gram of pups
produced whoops whoops sorry so let's
talk about the power of nesting when
nesting material was introduced in
catching during studies barbering
stopped fighting stopped animals ate
last breeding improved and the animals
just seemed happier more and more
studies are being published today that
prove that giving mice nesting material
not only is enrichment but as a cage
requirement along with water food and
bedding stops many of normal behaviors
we see in the lab today in giving an
enriched environment
that includes nesting material allows
more complex nest building chewing
forging and tunneling reduction in
stress improves the care of pups as well
as reduction in stress adds no variables
to the study so could research actually
have been improved so today's research
on nesting many aspects are being
studied what's the amount needed per
cage for appropriate behaviors what
types of materials are preferred what
happens within the cage environment when
nesting material is added studies have
been published regarding nest quality as
well as the amount of material needed to
build an adequate nest that allows for
thermal regulation some of the findings
have also shown that when my so give an
appropriate relevant nesting material
that allows them to thermoregulate they
will consume less diets as they are not
eating to stay warm and keep up their
energies as we discussed earlier wood
shavings allow for burrowing behaviors
this addresses only one of their nesting
instincts paper nesting products allow
the animals to build a nest they are
able to manipulate the paper and utilize
more of their natural instincts of chewy
fraying weaving and fluffy adding a
combination of products does two things
it allows them to utilize more behaviors
of sorting gathering carrying as well as
fraying and weaving but given to nesting
materials allows for the mice to have
material to line their nest making a
more complex type nest this picture
shows an enriched cage environment the
animals have two nesting substrates the
they have used to build a complex nest
they have lined their nest and some are
even in it they also have enrichment toy
to use the picture demonstrates how they
use the nesting material for sleeping
and thermal regulation but cannot to
play and move about the cage when they
are worn and want to play or eat so
let's talk about establishing a nesting
program when your facility starts to
look at adding nesting to your husband
requirements the first question to ask
would be why are you looking to improve
the cage environment its thermal
regulation and the animals need to
regulate their temperature important to
you are you looking to improve reading
animal welfare do you have abnormal
behaviors you are looking to stop for
example if you were looking to improve
the cage environment you would want a
nesting product that does not add dust
when being used by the animals if you
are looking for thermal regulation you
them and want a product that has 8 grams
of nesting material this is the amount
of nesting material that has been
terminus one important property of
nesting material is ease of use if you
have the best nesting material in the
market that money can buy but your staff
is not using it and put it in the cages
it does not matter animal welfare is
very important and we all take it
seriously hitting them products that do
not allow for nesting is frustrating for
them all of these points need to be
considered when deciding on a program
and which products to use cost is always
a factor but it should not be the
driving force you need to remember your
goal
so in today's market there are quite a
few products on the market for nesting
so again it's important to evaluate what
is available that meets your goals go to
the manufacturers website and learn
about what's offered can a product be
used more than once this is not only
cost effective but also allows the
animal to not be as stressed during a
cage change they have their familiar
smells and it's not traumatic i have
heard facilities say that eight grades a
product for thermal regulation and
breathing is too much I've heard I can't
see my animals well that is actually the
point they are in the nest to stay warm
and we'll come out when they are hungry
or hi this is normal mouse behavior
remember they don't like to be seen and
will hide from light and noise there are
products on the market today that are
easy to dispense proportions and
controlled this bodes well for ease of
use but also is cost effective using the
correct amount each and every time
allows for forecasting and doesn't waste
material there are products available
renner crinkle most nesting products
available today are made from paper this
allows for chewing manipulating framed
fluffing and there are many other
natural nesting behaviors there are also
products that are combination these
contain bedding and nesting materials
together in one bag this allows for easy
dispensing and adding another material
to this allows for two nesting
substrates and building the complex
dome-shaped nest mice can build a nest
and then line the nest with the other
substrate we saw that in the previous
picture of the enriched cage like I said
do your homework
as there is quite a few products
available today to choose from so let's
review this nesting material is
instinctive from eyes just like food
water and bedding is a requirement for a
mouse cage nesting materials should be
also it is a natural instinctive
behavior and allows them to make an
unnatural environment more natural their
environment today is very barren which
causes abnormal behaviors and added
stresses figure out what you're trying
to accomplish with your nesting program
are you giving them an ask for thermal
regulation and animal welfare are you
trying to increase your breathing are
you trying to give them some control
over their environment or are you just
trying to add something to check off a
box that you put something in the cage
in the end a nesting program is for the
animal which could aid in better
research the guide says that a
well-conceived enrichment program
provides animals with choices and a
degree of control over their environment
allowing them to better cope with
environmental stressors the bottom line
may actually be by giving mice nesting
material and ending the impoverished
environment may make for better research
as well as a better representative of
the species thank you I appreciate your
time and if there's any questions I'm
happy to answer them now or please feel
free to come to my stand if you think of
them later and we'll do a booth chat so
thank you
well thanking I here for that very
informative presentation um so during
the Q&A session I would like to remind
our audience of how to submit questions
you can submit questions by typing them
in the green Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window will try to answer as many
questions as we can our first question
for andrea is from Christina who asks in
Switzerland providing nesting material
is a legal requirement but no indication
is given on quality and quantity of
nesting material is there a preferred
material and is the and what is the
minimal amount per mouse while Christina
does a very good question so um not only
in Switzerland but nowhere is there a
mandate as to how much nesting material
to use most mandates say you need to put
something in the cage for singly housed
animals or just for breeders lots of
studies have been done in the past five
six years that state um if you're
looking to thermoregulate you need eight
grams of material now what does that
mean eight grams the material for how
many animals so what I tell my
facilities now is that you know we start
with one they usually have five mice
four to five mice in a cage and that has
worked out well I also have another
facility that doesn't think that's
enough and they add two um so it's kind
of for your preferences there's no
mandate now but I think as we go back to
you know what is important in to
integrating your nesting program you
need to you know play with what works
for you and what works for your animals
but if you want copies of the studies
that I have that talk about 8 to 11
grams I'm happy to email them to you
thank you for your question
okay great that was a great answer we
have another question from Paula who
asked I would like to know if you have
experience in nesting for rats and if
you have the same recommendations than
mice I actually do have a little
experience with nesting for rats most
people think rights don't nest what they
do and they do um not make the most
intricate nest as mice do but they do
nest I have a paper with paper products
on the market today that have been very
very um have done very well with rats
they have liked it besides the nesting
it's the tunneling and um they I always
thought that eight grams because is what
was recommended for mice would be too
little for ads but a couple facilities I
had did some testing and the eight grams
I didn't think it would work but it did
you know I figured they'd need 12 but
eight was sufficient enough and there
was two rats in the cage so I thought
that was pretty good but crinkle paper
has been on the most preferred nesting
material for rats and they seem to like
it better because they are able to
manipulate it and tunnel and play around
in it so thank you for your question
and we have another question along the
same line Marcel from the University of
Texas and Antonio it says excellent
presentation what is the single best
material for my verses rest for example
we tend to use nestlings for most mice
except nudes and enviro dry for rats but
I want to hear from you what your
advices for the ideal nesting material
well that's pret thank you for your your
question and I appreciate you coming to
my talk and I think enviro dry or
crinkle nest is the perfect product for
rat um they it's been proven they really
like it you're able to give them on
material that is crinkled and they are
able to manipulate it and they don't
have to work so hard to chew it up and
get some product I'm for mice um you
know the next one has been on the market
for ever it was the standard of you know
every cage got a desolate but with
studies being done and you know time
moving on and learning more things it's
really not on the best product now I
mean it by itself it's not enough
material I mean they have I think it's
three grams they have two and they have
a one which has been proven is in enough
material and it does have a lot of dust
issues which is why people don't use it
for nudes if you're looking for a
portion control of course veteran s
rocks it allows them to see through the
nest better because it's a straight
paper as opposed to the crinkled which
rats really like and you're able to use
it for more than one cage change which i
think is a big bonus some facilities use
the necklet with the better nest and
then that allows them to line their nest
also so I think with time and studies
going on
we're only going to get better with what
we are able to offer for nesting and i
think that the standard was an S lit but
I don't think it is anymore oh thank you
for your question thanks again for
attending my talk well that was very
interesting I'm so angry you mentioned
that the nesting amount is 8 grams but a
user asked what if the nesting material
we use is less than 8 grams and how
would that affect thermal regulation
well again thank you for your question
on studies have shown and have been
published that eight to 11 grams of
material was what was appropriate for
thermal regulation the reason being and
how they came upon that was by nest
quality and for mice to get in and to
get warm and to be covered you need a
lot of material and so if you don't have
if you have listened eight grams they're
not able to build the type of nests that
they need to build to be able to
thermoregulate and even though the eight
grams is on the lower side they said 11
was optimum and I said how you don't
need to see your animals all the time
because that was the point of nesting
and thermoregulation you do have to do
some health checks so 8 grams has become
the standard as the minimum of this
quality that will contribute to thermal
regulation so thank you for your
question okay we have one comment from
Marcel from the University of San of
texas-san Antonio Union who says thank
you for your response we placed
hypertensive rats on enviro and saw a 10
to 20 decrease in their mean blood
pressure I was so impressed by that
response do you have any comments to
that Andrea her dry or again crinkle
nest on embargo crinkle national being
the crinkled paper so if I found if you
give right straight paper it's it is
stressful because there they have to do
something with it but with the crinkle
you can put a handful in and they not
only um like Nessa and they love to roll
around in it that foraging they're
tunneling of course that would help
lower their blood pressure because
they're having fun they have something
that is good for them and that they
actually can use because you know a lot
of places give rats and ila bone and
okay they can chew with that but that's
not nesting and I really think that it's
part of their instinct and what you know
they have been bred for years and years
and years if they have to have a house
and I think enviro dry or clinical mask
or is a very good product for rats it's
the only thing I really recommend thank
you for your comment dr. Brad I'm glad
it's working for you that's great that's
really great so we have one more
question and and the person says if 8
grams are recommended why does your bed
Arness come in 4 grams as well ah that's
a very good question okay so um when
better masks being portion controlled
and we were really trying to get
something that was being revolutionary
and manufactured specifically for um
specifically for thermal regulation and
all the studies had been done with that
so um in our experience of taking it to
market a lot of facilities thought that
it was too much and again they couldn't
see their animal which is the point so
we offered a for gram to you know the
andersons like to listen to their
customers and see what they need with
quick taking the for gram to market I
found more people don't use it because
they'll take a sample of it and put it
in their cage and go well there's not
enough paper in there well that's right
because you need 8 grams for what you're
trying to accomplish so again when you
come up with an S
program you need to decide you know its
cost factor going to drive it or is it
thorough regulation animal welfare
stopping of normal behavior so then you
need to really look at what product
you're going to use because to just
throw something in there to say you did
you're not actually helping the animal
but you're also not working your program
and thinking about the animal welfare
which you know we all take very
seriously so we did offer a foreground
it's not a big seller because again it
doesn't do what the eight grand what
most people want nesting material to do
but look at people at you a choice so
thank you for your question I hope that
answered it so that was a really really
interesting material that you presented
Andrea I had no idea that nesting could
be could have so many variables um so if
there are no more questions I would like
to thank her speaker again and ask
andrea she has any final comments oh
thank everyone I appreciate you all
attending on my talk and again if you
think of any questions later on feel
free to email me or or come to our stand
and we can have a booth chat and I'm
happy to answer any other questions that
come up but thank you again for your
time well once again thank you andrea
for a fantastic presentation was really
really informative today's webcast will
be available for on-demand through
august 2 2016 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast is available for replay and we
invite you to for that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you again next
time and get back